this episode is sponsored by magellan tv
a documentary streaming service founded
by filmmakers journey to the microcosmos
viewers will get a one month free trial
of magellan tv by clicking the link in
the description
so
[Music]
the silliest we're going to talk about
today are kind of frustrating at this
point in our journey we've gotten used
to the fact that the microcosmos is an
indecipherable mess at times filled with
organisms that look like each other and
who have familial relationships that
seem obvious but then turn out to be
just figments of our own limited
imaginations
and these ciliates are yet another entry
in the long-standing saga of
ever-changing taxonomies that define
our understanding of microbial species
the plot twist
is inevitable
we are going to be showing you these
ciliates and talking about them like
they are related only to reveal at the
end that they are not nearly as closely
related as microbiologists once thought
but we still need to talk about these
ciliates because they are
inescapable they are always around
showing up in so many of our samples and
we also need to talk about the
associates because no matter how
frustrating they are
they are a ton of fun to watch
[Music]
these are a subclass affiliates called
hypotrix you might recognize that name
because it's shown up as a label on our
channel before and perhaps you've
wondered what exactly that means
hypotrix sounds quite cool but it's not
really a super helpful label if you
don't know what a hypotrek actually is
and that is why we're here today but
just so you know it's not a very
specific label it does not tell us a
whole lot about what species of
organisms we're looking at but sometimes
it's the best we can do after all there
are countless species of microbes in the
world many of which have names buried in
books and papers that we haven't even
come across yet and many others which
literally don't have names yet
so for james our master of microscopes
and it should be said a connoisseur of
ciliate labeling microbes sometimes
becomes a matter of figuring out just
how specific he can get
sometimes the best he can do is
something very broad just calling it a
silliate but sometimes there are details
that help him narrow down a little
closer and hyper tricks have some pretty
helpful details
for one they usually have a big mouth
and a flat body some even have
interesting pigments like the gold
dotting this frantically spiraling
individual or this pink tinted one now
we're not sure what those pigments are
or what purpose they serve though based
on what we've seen in other organisms
they could be ways to block harmful uv
light from the sun but things like a
flat body or big mouth or pigments are
not enough what really sets hypotricks
apart from other ciliates is their thick
hair
[Music]
ciliates are hairy single-celled
creatures they are surrounded by these
thin fibrous organelles called cilia and
the arrangement of these cilia do so
much to shape the way these organisms
live from the way they move around the
micro cosmos to the food the cilia draw
in towards the organism's mouth but even
among ciliates hypotrics stand out for
how they use cilia they are not content
to just have the thin structures their
compatriots do no hyperdricks take these
individual cilia and bundle them
together into something bigger called a
seri like a rope made of smaller strands
in some species they may even have more
than a hundred cilia fused together in
their serie and it's thanks to these
cyri that hypotrics do something unusual
for single-celled organisms
they
walk
you can really see it with this aspa
disca which looks like it's crawling
across the screen like a little cartoon
bug so these seerai help us know that we
are looking at a hypotric ciliate but to
narrow down the genus or species we need
to be able to see all of the seri so we
can make out the patterns they form
along the hypotrick's body and it can be
tough to see all those crai which is why
we often cannot identify our hypotrics
but there are some genuses that make it
easier on us
for example this sticker trick has a
really distinct look thanks to its shape
and the spiral of cyride traveling down
it and then there's this diaphras which
has well it has a hairy butt and that
makes it pretty easy to identify it's
also very fast we actually had to record
this in slow motion to be able to show
it to you but this is where things get
confusing and complicated it's where
that plot twist comes in the one we told
you about in the beginning so it's not
really a plot twist anymore it's like
watching the empire strikes back for the
15th time when you know what's coming
though i guess in this version the
family bonds are getting broken instead
of revealed
because we're talking about all these
organisms like they're hypotrics except
that it's not clear whether that's
actually what they are and when we've
been diving into the literature the
classifications get kind of confusing
what makes us feel better about
ourselves is that it seems like the
biologists find it a bit unfathomable as
well the 1979 edition of the ciliated
protozoa describes the taxonomy of
hypotrix as aggravating
it's good when scientists just tell it
like it is decades later in 2021 a paper
described them as quote one of the most
confused groups in terms of their
systematics
it turns out that what defines an
organism as a hypotric or even a
particular subclass of hypotric depends
so much on what you are reading
one of the recent works dedicated to
bringing more order to silent
classification found there were at least
10 different taxonomic systems devised
around categorizing hypertricks and
that's how you get to a story like the
tale of euplotes
these ciliates were first described in
1733
and about a hundred years later the
german microbiologist christian
ehrenberg created the genus euplotes
around them and they would end up being
lumped in with many other hypotrics as
their own subclass becoming one of the
old guards of the hypotrix
except eventually for taxonomic reasons
the euplotes eventually
became their own thing separate from the
hypotrics but still related the hypotrix
and euplotes simply became relatives
grouped together under a different
family name the spyro tricks
and on the one hand this is the kind of
thing that makes hypertricks and i guess
spyro tricks as well so frustrating to
talk about but it's also something very
cool it's like the microcosmos has a
library that is constantly acquiring new
books and the more we read those books
and add new ones to our shelves the more
we find ourselves needing to rearrange
them so their location
and neighbors reflect
all that we have discovered
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
magellan tv for sponsoring this episode
of journey to the micro cosmos if you're
looking for some more microscopic
content be sure to check out magellan
tv's life on us a microscopic safari
where they explore the creatures that
live compete feed and breed on the
surface or in the depths of our body
magellan tv is a documentary streaming
service founded by filmmakers it has
some of the most in-depth science
content available anywhere covering
space technology nature and more 15 to
20 hours of new content is added each
week with a growing collection of 4k
high definition content for no
additional cost so you'll never run out
of something to watch and there are no
ads magellan tv can be watched anytime
anywhere on your television laptop or
mobile device because it is compatible
with roku amazon fire tv apple tv google
play and ios click on the link in the
description to get your first full month
of magellan tv for free
[Music]
the folks on your screen right now
they're the least frustrating thing in
this video i can tell you that they are
our patreon patrons and they want it to
be possible for us to continue banging
our heads against books trying to figure
out the relationships between
hypertricks we'll figure it out someday
but anyway thank you so much to all of
our patreon patrons if you would like to
join them and be one of the reasons why
we can make this show at all that's
patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]